welcome to the urban Institute's first
Tuesday our topic today is the fiscal
cliff like to welcome everybody in the
room those who are watching us on c-span
and those who are watching us on the web
my name is Howard Glickman i'm a
resident fellow at the Urban Institute
and editor of the urban Brookings Tax
Policy Center blog tax box the fiscal
cliff is a phrase I suspect most of us
hoped we would never hear again I'm born
out of the great debt limit battle of
2011 the cliff was intended to be a
fiscal wound so severe that would drive
Congress and the president to agree on a
long-term plan to reduce the deficit the
idea was the Democrats would agree to
cut spending and Republicans would
consent to raise taxes over the next
decade all necessary compromises to
avoid the deep immediate spending cuts
and massive tax increases that will
occur if government toppled over the
cliff at the time some some skeptics
predicted a different outcome they
figured Congress and the White House
would agree on only one thing and that
was to find a way to duck the
consequences through delay and
obfuscation that's largely what Congress
did on new years but it did do other
things as well so now over the next few
months we face a veritable Grand Canyon
of fiscal cliffs one budget crisis after
another between now and March to explain
what happened a week ago and what is
likely to happen over the next few
months we have three of Washington's
most respected budget experts to my left
is Donald Marron who's former acting
director of the Congressional Budget
Office former member of President Bush's
Council of Economic Advisers and
currently the director of the Tax Policy
Center
Rudy Penner to my far left is former
director of CBO former assistant
director of the Office of Management
budget and currently an Institute fellow
with the Urban Institute between them is
Bob Reischauer
who is also a former director of of the
Congressional Budget Office and
president emeritus of the Urban
Institute before we get started a few
housekeeping issues each of our speakers
will talk for about five or six minutes
I'll ask them some questions we'll talk
among ourselves and then we'll open it
up to questions from all of you
for those of you who are watching on
c-span are watching on the web you you
may send us questions by emailing public
affairs all one word at urban org
that's public affairs at urban org and
I'd ask you to please you're please
leave it keep your questions brief and
also send us your name and your
affiliation our first speaker will be
Dyle Marin he'll be talking to us a
little bit about the tax consequences of
the cliff we sit here on January 8th and
has already been an incredibly busy year
for Tax Policy Howard said I'd like to
talk about the tax consequences of the
cliff and the deal that was struck to
avert it back in October my colleagues
and I issued a report that looked at all
the tax things were bundled up in the
fiscal cliff you had on your seat and
you see on the screens and perhaps at
home you see on your screens a chart of
our primary results of that study of
what was looming and what was possible
in the fiscal cliff and what I want to
do is just quickly remind those who have
seen it before introduce those who have
not what this chart shows and then
compare it to what actually happened
okay so what the chart here shows is how
much people's tax rates would have gone
up if we fell entirely off the fiscal
cliff so the vertical read it as being
in percentage points if you look at the
all column to the far right you'd see
that on average across all taxpayers at
the end of last year tax rates were
scheduled to go up by about five
percentage points okay which is a lot
there's a reason that people in
Washington and the commentariat were
freaking out about that that would be a
gigantic tax increase what we have on
the left of the chart here is lining up
households by how much income they earn
so you can see what the effect would be
on households of different income levels
we divide them into fifths from lowest
to top so for example you can see that
in the middle quintile kind of the
middle income folks in our nation they
were scheduled to have a tax increase of
just short of four percentage points
that would have raised their tax rate
from about 14% on average at the federal
level to about 18% and that would have
been the equivalent of about
$2,000 and then the other group I'm
going to particularly focus on the top
1% since they were such a focus of the
debates we saw you can see that they
were scheduled if we went entirely off
the cliff to have a bigger tax increase
in percentage terms percentage point
terms that would have been about seven
percentage points would have raised
their tax rate from about 31% to 38%
okay so first conclusion of our study
was it was a big deal there was a big
pending tax cut basically for all
Americans right you can see from lowest
to highest virtually all Americans would
have had a significant tax increase if
we went entirely off the cliff very
somewhat by income level was somewhat
higher at high income levels the other
big result was the color scheme you see
here that a lot of the focus on the
fiscal cliff was about the tax cuts that
were originally enacted under President
Bush in 2001 and 2003 those grabbed the
headlines but the reality is there was
actually many many other tax provisions
that were either expiring or starting at
the start of the year and that it was
also important to distinguish different
categories of tax cuts among those that
were originally enacted in 2001 and 2003
and so what my colleagues and I did is
we went through all of the tax
provisions that were part of the fiscal
cliff where we put them into nine
different bins which I realize is a lot
but they were all important and distinct
and we thought it was useful to track
them you can see them on the sheet of
paper in front of you or hopefully on on
the screen here they included such
things as the alternative minimum tax
patch we've just lived through about a
decade in which the alternative minimum
tax was scheduled to expand to many more
households from roughly three or four
million households to roughly 25 or 30
million households but Congress would
periodically step in to prevent that and
one of the big questions that the cliff
was whether they would do that there
were the tax cuts that were enacted
under President Bush originally that
primarily affected low and moderate
income households there were then of
course also the ones that primarily
affected high-income households both on
their ordinary income and on the ones
affected capital income capital gains
and dividends in orange on the chart
here you can see that there was the
estate tax the estate tax was scheduled
to go up at the beginning of the year
you can see in a lighter orange things
called the extenders
this is several dozen provisions mostly
corporate some individual that have been
renewed for a year at a time typically
sometimes two years but are scheduled to
expire and virtually all of those were
scheduled to expire at the end of last
year some had actually expired at the at
the at the beginning of the year you see
in the light yellow here that President
Obama enacted back in 2009 some tax
credits that were particularly focused
on lower-income and moderate income
folks those were scheduled to expire at
the beginning of the year and then you
see in blue at the bottom the payroll
tax cut two years ago there was an acted
a temporary payroll tax cut as a form of
economic stimulus you can see that in
particular affects folks at all income
levels and that was scheduled to expire
at the end of the year end of last year
okay and so this was what was teed up
that basically oh I'm sorry I left out
one and then also sort of in a purpley
color just above the blue there there
were the taxes that were originally
enacted in 2010's health reform that
were scheduled to begin at the end to
begin at the beginning of this year and
so you have all these different tax
provisions that were scheduled to strike
at the start of the year
take them all together they add up to a
pretty big hit and now if the flipping
works we'll see this is what actually
happened okay so same scale same
structure this is what happens under the
American Taxpayer Relief Act and let me
just do my flippy-flippy a little bit
here so you can kind of visualize what's
going on in your mind a couple things
that leap out okay first of all the bars
on what actually happened are by and
large much lower than what we're
scheduled to happen in rough orders of
magnitude the Act that was signed into
law last week avoided just less than 2/3
of the scheduled fiscal cliff so a
little more than a third of the cliff
happened and a little less than 2/3 of
it was avoided the part that happened at
the part that happened as you can see
here then for most Americans was the
expression of the payroll tax cut now
that was something that was always
intended as a temporary tax cut it was
stimulus we knew one day it would go
away
the political debate would be when and
Congress and the president decided that
now is the time then after two years the
payroll tax cut would be allowed to
expire as a result essentially all
working
American families are seeing their taxes
go up this year relative to what they
were last year by around one percentage
point on average it's actually a two
percentage point for those who are
working as one percentage across all
households so that's the biggest part
for the vast majority of Americans that
what actually was allowed to happen in
the cliff if you look over at the top
one percent though you can see that
essentially three other things happened
okay again in the purplish color you can
see that the tax increases that were
scheduled in 2010's health reform went
into effect those are almost
overwhelmingly focused on folks earning
two hundred thousand or two hundred
fifty thousand dollars or more and in
the grayish color here you can see that
the tax cuts originally enacted in 2001
and 2003 we're not allowed to entirely
continue and in fact most of them
expired you can see that not all of them
expired the gray bars on the original
chart are larger than the ones that that
actually go into effect for example
dividend taxes were scheduled to rise
back up to ordinary tax rates at the end
of the year the new law instead just
keeps them at capital gains rates rising
to 20 plus of course the health reform
taxes and whereas the fiscal cliff would
have had the new 39 or the old thirty
nine point six percent tax bracket kick
in at a lower rate lower income level
under the deal that was struck that
kicks in for folks who have taxable
income a four hundred thousand or four
hundred and fifty thousand dollars or
higher so most of the cliff takeaway
here most of the cliff was avoided the
AMT patch was solved and in fact was
patched permanently and so from a budget
and geek point of view I actually find
that nice in terms of communications
that at least we will no longer be
constantly having discussions about is
the AMT patched or not patched it is now
permanently patched the majority of the
the kind of low and middle income tax
cuts that were enacted under President
Bush were fully extended President
Obama's credits that were enacted in
2009 were not permanently extended but
they were extended for five years
most of the extenders were continued you
can see there's just a little sliver of
orange and yellow here the estate tax
deal and the extender deal that were
enacted didn't avoid the
entire cliffs but they in voided the
vast majority of the cliff for those
provisions and then just quickly the
other quick takeaway you can have from
this chart is obviously what the pattern
is that in the full fiscal cliff most
Americans were looking at an average tax
increase of three or four percentage
points and at the very high end it was
about seven percentage points what
happened is that at low and moderate
income levels folks avoided at least
two-thirds if not more of the pending
tax increases but folks in the top 1%
didn't get as much of a break but you'll
see that their average tax and tax rate
went up by about 5 percentage four and a
half percentage points here they were
saved from in essence one third of the
cliff that was facing them and they bore
the brunt of the other two thirds and
that President Obama has in fact been
successful in his goal of having more of
the tax burden shifted to high-income
folks and with that well thank you Bob
okay pleasure to be here with you I was
at a gathering on Saturday night and I
was asked how on a 1 to 10 scale would I
score the outcome of the fiscal cliff
negotiation and without a whole lot of
thought I confess I said I give it a 2
and that might be generous the people
who I were was with were a little taken
aback by my negative appraisal because
they like most Americans were relieved
that this episode of the fiscal Perils
of Pauline was over at least for a few
weeks and there wasn't a collapse of
financial markets there wasn't huge tax
increases on all of us and all the other
dire ramifications of failure that the
media and the pundits had been
hyperventilating about for two months
didn't come to past quite naturally we'd
had a few glasses of wine and I was told
that I had to defend my score and why I
was so pessimistic
which I did by explaining what I thought
would be needed to earn a 10 and then
comparing it to what we got out
the other end now I want a note that
after 42 years in Washington I'm not so
naive as to believe that we ever could
have done anything close to a 10 but you
know given the domestic political
environment the international situation
that were in the weakness of our economy
you know probably nothing above and 7 or
Nate was was in the cards but it's worth
looking at a 10 and comparing it to what
we have to realize why we are not in the
best of all possible worlds at this
point ok issue one is really the big
enchilada which is dealing with the long
term fiscal balance that we face in a
sensible way and I would have given a 10
to what folks were talking about but
knew was unachievable which was the
grand bargain between the president and
the congressional leaders on a package
of tax and spending policies that over
the next 10 12 years would have
stabilized the debt to GDP ratio and
that would have been a package somewhere
in the 2 to 3 trillion dollar range of
course you know there really wasn't time
the time you would need to between the
election in January first the work out
all those details so irrespective of the
fact that we have two political parties
snarling at each other and not a whole
lot in the way of negotiations you know
that really wasn't in the cards but a 9
which would have come from enacting some
big pieces quote down payment
accompanied by a framework that would
specify how the rest of the puzzle would
be put together over the next six months
with some credible enforcement mechanism
that
would ensure the the balance of the
undone task would be accomplished such a
framework might have included an
agreement to increase revenues from tax
reform reduce entitlement spending
through similar reforms of somewhere
around 1.2 trillion dollars on each side
- whatever was part of the down payment
agreement of course we came up shall I
say a bit short of this so you know - is
I think a charitable grade-one a second
big concern about the fiscal cliff issue
was that it had dire consequences for
our fragile economy and we might have
pushed the economy back into recession
as CBO and others had warned if the
fiscal cliff sort of was prolonged and
went for a whole calendar or fiscal year
none of that was really in the cards if
we were over for two weeks two months
whatever a score of ten on this
dimension would have included in my view
some short-term measures to stimulate
the economy combined with this two to
three trillion dollar reduction in
deficits over a 10-year period but given
the political makeup that was never in
the cards but you know what about a nine
nine would have adhered to the fiscal
Hippocratic oath do no harm and you know
on on balance I think we got a middling
grade on this extended unemployment
benefits were continued for another year
in those states where
the recession has hit most severely the
majority of taxpayers majority I used
that that's what we refer to ninety nine
point three percent of the population
was spared a income tax increase and we
enacted a permanent patch to the
alternative minimum tax thereby
protecting 30 odd million households
from something that they were totally
unaware they were about to get hit with
which was a very considerable increase
in their liabilities for calendar year
2012 but on the other side and why this
isn't the seven on this dimension or
even an eight the payroll tax holiday
from which all working Americans have
benefited over the last two years was
not continued and that will decrease
take-home pay over the course of the
next year for the average American
family buy something over a thousand
bucks and this is money that is going to
reduce consumption you know I think a
more sensible approach would have been
to say we're going to phase this out and
I've been an advocate of phasing it out
for over a year and you know extend one
percentage point reduction in the
payroll tax for 2013 and then have it
disappear
in 2014 overall on taxes I would give
the deal a very very low score the
amount of revenue that was generated by
the deal was lower that far lower than
the president and the Democrats had
hoped for and even lower than the amount
that the Republicans seemed willing at
various times to put on the
table the tax code is horrendously
complicated component of American life
and if anything and I would defer to
Donald on this it's more complicated
today than it was you know a few weeks
ago notwithstanding the president's
references to the top 2% being affected
by higher income tax rates the fraction
is I think something under 1% about 7
tenths of a percent or something around
there so you know this this was
sacrifice visited upon a very very tiny
fraction of the population and just to
make sure that you know that group
didn't leave the table hungry we made
modifications in the estate tax that you
know allowed for exemptions of 10
million dollars for couples and indexed
these in the future so we've made that
part of their lives
a good deal happier problem from my
perspective probably the worst worse
than the failure to adhere to the
president's initial two hundred thousand
two hundred and fifty thousand dollar
threshold for where higher tax income
tax burdens would start is the fact that
members of both parties you know quite
vocally and quite prominently are saying
that these rates that we have adopted
are permanent we are permanently
extending the Bush tax credit and I
think this will create the impression
among many that tax at least rates are
off the table in the future when in fact
you know we've done a quarter of maybe
what we should do and that is is very
damaging I think anyone who looks
objectively at the budget challenges
that lie ahead
would have to conclude that if we're
going to reduce deficits to acceptable
and sustainable levels and we're going
to continue to provide the majority of
Americans with the services that they
want and expect and the services that
are needed to make our economy
competitive or continue to be
competitive
either through higher rates or through
base watering or more likely through a
combination of the two we're going to
have to visit increased taxes on not the
1% not the 2% probably not the 20% but
the 30 or 40 percent of Americans and
you know the sooner we face up to that
the sooner we can get on to other
important issues that the government
should be addressing fourth goal of the
fiscal cliff negotiations was to provide
more in the way of certainty for those
running businesses for those responsible
for administering federal state local
programs and for citizens who are
dependent on government services and on
this dimension I think it's very hard to
say that any progress was made at all
the sequester still looms the debt
ceiling hasn't been increased the
continuing resolution which is what this
government is running on right now
rough still runs out on March 27th the
sustainable growth rate doc cut of
twenty seven point four percent was
pushed off for another year in other
words we have everything that we had
before in the way of uncertainty but the
path forward is if anything murkier than
it was on December 31st and in many ways
the consequences of failure to resolve
any of these issues is probably greater
or who are greater now than they were at
the end of 2012
finally there was the hope that
successful resolution of the fiscal
cliff debate would both clear the decks
for other important legislative
priorities immigration just to name one
and create a more constructive less
partisan less toxic environment in which
the Congress could prove to be more
productive and that he'll executive
branch relationships would be improved
on this dimension I fear that things
that Veni if if they've changed at all
they've deteriorated at a minimum the
first six months of this calendar year
are going to be absorbed tried to deal
with all of these issues that were
resolved at the end of 2012 and we're
just going to be consumed by sons of
fiscal cliff you know and they might
come in packages together or they might
be in individual components the
expectations I think of the two parties
for the next round are as wide if not
wider than they were several months ago
and both parties have been drawing and
redrawing in the same place their lines
in the sand and unfortunately those
lines are in unsustainable place so was
I a tough grader
Oh Bob thank you for that optimistic
analysis Rudy can you give us any more
of a sense of optimism
well thanks Howard I think the important
question is what happens next and I
suppose if I were brutally honest I
would say I don't have a clue but it's
fun to speculate even about bad things
and I'll do my best I do I would do
Bob's pessimism because I think as he
implied things certainly haven't started
out auspiciously since the cliff deal
was consummated the Republicans are very
upset because they feel the president
mocked them and campaign-style meeting
he had after the deal was announced
they're not keen to negotiate with the
president for that and other reasons on
his part the president has adamantly
said he will not negotiate over the debt
ceiling and this has led some
Republicans and some outside groups as
well more bipartisan groups to advocate
that really the Congress should try and
resolve this issue on its own using what
they call regular order and I think what
they mean by that is that the Congress
should go ahead pass a budget resolution
have that resolution contained
reconciliation instructions which is a
fancy phrase for having them tell
various committees how much revenues to
raise or how much to slow down the
growth of spending and maybe to put
something horrible in it that will
happen if they don't follow through
we saw how well that worked with the
supercommittee
I think there are really two basic
problems with this approach one there
just simply isn't enough time I suppose
they could give themselves more time by
temporarily raising the debt limit
postponing a sequester yet again
and extending the CR but that would be
extreme can kicking but even if they
give themselves more time the Congress
as the whole can't pass a budget
resolution unless both the House and the
Senate passed their own and the Senate
hasn't done that for a number of years
and I think it would be even harder for
them now because the one thing that the
deal did was to pick the lowest of the
low hanging fruit by increasing taxes on
the hyper rich by so what significant
amount and on the not so rich rich by a
somewhat lower amount well even if I'm
wrong and the Senate would be able to
come up with a budget resolution I find
it hard to believe that I have a Senate
conference led by Paul Ryan and patty
Murray is going to come up with anything
very useful so my short-run prediction
is that we'll go back to relying on
those old warriors Senator McConnell and
the vice president to come up with
something and I think what we'll witness
is then vigorously arguing over how far
to kick the can down the road this time
now before the fiscal cliff deal that
was a so very pessimistic and even
worried that we might possibly fall off
the cliff by accident which luckily
didn't happen I think it even less
likely that we would default on the
national debt by accident during the
Cold War we used to say that nuclear the
use of nuclear weapons was deterred by
the so-called mad doctrine that is the
mutually assured destruction I think if
we really did default even for a short
period of time that would truly be a
nuclear war with devastating
consequences well for the longer run I
become even more and more depressed if
that's possible
during during the campaign well and Bob
implied this but during the campaign the
president strongly promised that he'd
get spare the middle class from any pain
in the form of tax increases or by
having to give up things that they think
they've been promised and certainly the
Republicans are not going to lead a
crusade to raise middle class taxes and
somewhat to my surprise since the
campaign it seems to me that the
president's doubled down on that promise
by often mentioning how much he will
protect the middle class and certainly
the middle class is very much in style
with the Republicans as well but
unfortunately as Bob also implied the
arithmetic clearly shows that you can't
solve this long-run budget problem
without the middle class making a
contribution
the problem with rich people is that
there just aren't enough of them even if
you have bowles-simpson type reform
revenue raising reform it's bound to
raise the tax burden significantly on a
very large number of middle-class people
who rely heavily on deductions and
exclusions but on the other side again
Bob implied that the President must know
that he's not going to have a very happy
second term unless a very large part of
the long-run budget problem is solved on
his watch otherwise he's going to face a
whole series of fiscal cliffs and cliff
hats that greatly restrict his ability
to make progress like Bob said on
immigration reform education
infrastructure etc etc so I think that
he'd be very keen to cut a deal
and indeed bend over backwards to do so
but he certainly hasn't talked that way
yet so consequently I feel no reason to
abandon the forecast I've been making
for a very long
time and that is that it's going to take
a sovereign debt crisis to get our
leaders to act responsibly if that does
happen I think groups like the AARP who
have adamantly imposed even the tiniest
of reforms of entitlement spending will
see that they have been very
short-sighted their constituents will be
hurt my delayed by if their retirement
savings evaporate in a market crash what
we've seen in Europe under similar
circumstances is very dramatic changes
in pensions without without much notice
so I very much hope that will happen but
I guess I'm not ready to change in my
forecast yet thank you thank you so Bob
and Rudy gave us less than optimistic of
prognostication Donald you're usually a
pretty optimistic guy for an economist
is there anything that came out of this
that leads you to believe that things
may turn out better than Bob and Rudy
suggests yeah so I was chatting with a
colleague earlier and I was joking that
sometimes I feel like Pollyanna with low
expectations and so therefore you know
like don't disagree with the absolute
grade but if going in you know I thought
a good outcome was a three and a zero
and one or on the table you know two is
not a bad outcome I'd say I have one
thing one thing stands out for me and
this is so forgive me because this is a
process-oriented thing but it strikes me
so I've been doing tax policy in
Washington on and off for about ten
years and the one nice thing about this
deal is it resolves whether you like it
or not it resolves some issues that
people have been fighting about those
entire ten years okay so not fully but
like this whole issue of patching the
AMT right it's been hanging out there
ever since the tax cuts were enacted in
2001 and okay hasn't completely
eliminated the AMT but it has freed
mental bandwidth to not worry about what
are we going to do about the AMT this
year and next year and I mean this both
in a personal sense
aha I get to think about new things so
I'm happy because I like new things not
fighting about old things but it's also
true that policymakers and their teams
have limited bandwidth and if you say to
them every year you've got to do an AMT
patch that means some very bright
talented industrious people have to
waste some time up on the hill figuring
out how to do an AMT patch they're now
free from that same thing is true for
the vast majority of the 2001 2003 tax
cuts right you may like or may not like
how it was resolved but whatever was
done is now permanent I mean in the
sense that anything in Washington is
permanent right it's embodied in law it
would acquire new congressional efforts
to change not congressional action to go
away
and that frees up mine share to think
about the kinds of issues that Bob and
Rudy were raising about well what do we
want our tax system to look like same
thing with the estate tax same thing
with the payroll tax cut right which is
you know a not a bad way to do economic
stimulus given that it's way to move a
large amount of money but it's now in
the rearview mirror and now I think
there is an opportunity for folks
interested in tax to be more
forward-looking to spend more time
thinking about how you go after
deductions and exemptions and exclusions
how you clean up the tax code how you
make it simpler
I'm not Pollyannish enough to think that
that's going to be easy right recognize
that one of the things we've lost is the
leverage point of all these explorations
forcing action although I must admit
I've become increasingly cynical over
time at the ability of these things to
force good action seeing what's actually
happened but I'd like to think we have
freed up some policy mindshare to think
about the the bigger issues that Bob
Rudy raised Rudy let me ask you about
this question the permanence of the tax
code Donald just gave a good argument
for for why making these provisions
permanent might be a useful saying Bob
made an argument for why it may not be
because of this implication that these
are the rates are permanent in fact off
the table what's your sense of this is
it a good thing or a bad thing that
we've made much of the code permanent
well that's the first really big good
thing which doesn't go directly to your
question is that we did a boy
this humongous tax increase that would
have almost certainly caused a recession
if it is been left that way I guess I
don't make us much out of calling these
extensions permanent
as does Donald and Bob because I think
we will be talking a great deal about
tax reform in over the next year and we
won't be restrained by the notion that
we should keep these things steady for a
good long time and of course if we have
tax reform and if it turns out well what
we will have is a simpler more efficient
tax code with lower rates now I don't
want to underestimate the difficulty of
achieving that it's going to be very
very hard especially if we try to raise
revenues with tax reform but I don't
think we'll be restrained by what we did
in this deal no I just want to say why I
don't agree with you which is you know
when you make something permanent then
there's no requirement that the Congress
deal with an issue main namely deficits
what you do is you wait around twiddle
your thumbs until the sovereign debt
crisis forces you to do something if you
extend the tax cuts for two years you
know in two years there has to be a
debate nasty as it is the one we had
again and forcing Congress to be
inactive is not hard forcing it to act
when it when the action implies
unpleasant things for constituents is
very hard and you also want those
unpleasant things to affect the most
constituents possible to get action and
you know I you know could have given a
three
you know if they done this same task up
but just for three years some
like that because I have some assurance
that you know we be back in the in the
fray again but just a comment on
Donald's uh you know what are your
expectations and one two three Donald
you know teaches at Georgetown and I
want to be one of his students if he
grades on that kind of curve Rudy we
well I was just going to say in the good
old days we changed the tax law a good
deal and we thought each change was
permanent in the good old days I do have
to admit the system didn't seem to be as
completely broken as it is today and you
know the prime I'm really at a loss for
what kind of thing might cause the
Congress to act in a sensible way we've
reduced the credibility of using
something like this sequester just hard
to come up with artificial crises of
that sort so in in a sense it'd be nice
I suppose if we had even more things
expiring but I tend to favor Donald to
you that it's good to get that off the
table it's good not to have long debates
every year about extending rates and so
I'm not as worried about as Bob that it
makes a good deal the difference as to
whether we call these things permanent
or temporary well but it's not hard for
the Congress to patch the AMT or extend
tax rates at their low level you know
these are good II what they struggle
over is you know do we have to pay for
it and if we don't pay for it how are we
going to deal with our guilt you know
and you know there aren't a lot of
people maybe there are you're in the tax
world I'm not who sit around and worry
about should we patch the alternative
minimum tax
or if we do patch the alternative
minimum tax
how will we construct the patch the
answer is the same way we've done for
the last nine years you know it's it's
just this sort of what do you do how do
you come up with the money or the
rationalization for not providing the
money to allow yourself to do this I
want to ask about we've talked a little
bit about process and I have to say that
from my own perspective I think one of
the things we learned over the last few
years is we try all of these budget
processes and nothing seems to work but
it does leave another pressure point and
that's the markets and I wonder I mean
given the fact that interest rates are
negative at the moment there isn't much
incentive for a politician to make the
tough votes they have to make so does do
any of you think that we then absent a
revolt of the BOD vigilantes that were
were ever going to get action in
Washington or task it the other way
would a reaction a negative reaction by
the bond market finally get Congress and
the president to do what they're not
willing to do
Reed well I was surprised during the
debate over the fiscal cliff that
markets were so calm I expected a lot
more volatility and I'm still scratching
my head over why every little wiggle and
the discussion of Greece's sovereign
debt crisis seemed to cause our market
to go up or down by the whole GDP of
Greece when when this much more pressing
worry about what we do with a fiscal
cliff didn't seem to cause that much
volatility now I suspect that what the
markets learned from the 2011 so-called
crisis is that the Congress will act to
prevent the really great harm from being
done it at the very last minute so what
that does is mean that it's less
probable that I think as we approach the
dead limb at this time and and the other
cliff
that the market is really going to
pressure us into action but to me the
interesting thing about sovereign debt
crises is you look at the history of
those things is that markets tend to
remain very very calm as a budget
situation deteriorates until one day
they don't it's not a gradual process as
neil ferguson is pointed out these
things are essentially impossible to
predict they can be set off by a bit of
bad budget news on another wise slow
news day well yeah you know unlike
Greece and other countries Argentina
that have been in sovereign that crises
it isn't that we don't have the ability
the financial ability to solve the
problem they don't
I mean Greece within its borders doesn't
have that we do we lack the will the
political will and so you know it's a
very different kind of situation the
other thing to keep in mind is you know
we haven't got the usual signal from
bond markets or interest rates that you
know you're living beyond your means you
know interest rates are going to go up
because we have a weak economy and our
Fed has taken the the set of policies to
say through two years from now we're
going to keep interest rates close to
zero and that's a very kind of unusual
thing because it has eliminated one of
the signals that the public and markets
and leaders look to forcing action so
what do you think well so I'd say that I
mean my reading is so clearly the Fed is
having an impact but I would say
actually the markets themselves without
the Fed interaction are also telling us
that interest rates at this point in
time should be incredibly low because of
a weak global economy and and they're
still still relatively tepid us
and you know so on the one hand I'm a
card-carrying deficit Hawk and I can
talk you know you know us financial
fiscal crisis with the best of them on
the other hand I don't really feel in my
heart so maybe I'll go down in the
history books now as being the Pollyanna
who was wrong right before it broke but
you know the hypothetical fiscal crisis
for the United States is still many
years in the future but it isn't
something that's about to right crop up
on us how I go sell and you know the
world is telling us sending us a signal
with incredibly low interest rates and
that that of course is making it easier
for us to maintain our relatively
profligate waves the you know as bob
says you know we have the power to get
back on its trajectory that it works and
then it's the usual thing of how do you
do hard things right in your personal
life if you've ever read any Helen any
self-help books by anyone at all right
you know about the urgent pile and the
important pile and the challenge is you
got caught up all the time doing the
urgent stuff and you forget about the
important stuff the same thing happens
at the federal level that in the push of
things the urgent stuff the crises are
what get attention right that's
basically the way we making fiscal
policy for the last few years is
whatever whatever is urgent but you do
have moments when something important
gets addressed and the way you get
something important addressed is through
leadership right is to look forward to
Marshall support for doing something
large and I think you know it's it's
obviously given me the political
constellation that we have it's not an
easy thing to do but one of the things
we should encourage and aspire for our
president and congressional leaders to
do is to show some leadership and say
okay now that some of these crises okay
so there are now three more crises just
lined up for the next couple months but
assuming we have to survive those once
the crises are in the rearview mirror
can we all fight show some leadership
get together choose some some big things
that we can I can attempt to do tax
reform would be a fine choice I think
though the low interest rates are really
important in depriving us of an
important argument for getting the
budget under control I've always been
fascinated by the fact
that the Canadians were able to turn the
public around from cheering on spending
to really opposing any deficit deficits
at all and if you talk to Canadian
politicians they say they're single most
effective argument was that interest was
taking 40 percent of their revenues and
they could convince the public that debt
was bad and we just don't have that
argument right now remember James
Carville famous quote during the Clinton
administration that after he died he
wanted to come back reincarnated as the
bond market because that was clearly
limiting what they felt they could do in
terms of their policy agenda at the time
as far as I know there's no one in
humanity who would currently like to be
reincarnated as the bond market let me
ask a little bit about tax reform first
question is do any of you think that we
could conceivably do tax reform without
an agreement first on how much money we
think this new tax code needs to raise
in other words without an agreement on
revenues could does it even make sense
to try to do tax reform so by large no
there is there is this open question
about whether you could peel off a piece
that everyone was comfortable having be
a revenue neutral and you had an agreed
baseline for what revenue neutrality
would be and whether you could move
around the things in there people
sometimes talk about doing business or
corporate tax reform in that context
that is much much harder to do than the
words I just spoke but you know and once
you start doing fundamental tax reform
it's virtually impossible to fundamental
tax reform without knowing what revenue
target you're trying to hit Bob what do
you think no I think that's right yeah
so so we we could put tax reform off the
table until they can agree on a revenue
number which we don't think they're
really going to do yes certainly thinks
that I guess okay let me try to be a
little optimistic about taxes if I can't
I'm gonna try here it was interesting to
me that during the debate both during
the presidential campaign and for a
while during the fiscal cliff debate
there was an interesting discussion
about this idea of capping or limiting
deductions and it seemed to actually get
support from across the aisle Bob do you
think that there's anything to build on
from that discussion you don't want to
start with somebody who's going to be
more optimistic you know my answer is no
because the big bucks are the deductions
exclusions that effect the middle class
and that are very popular and you know
everybody's for it in the abstract but
when you bring the plane from 30,000
feet down to you know ground level you
know people want to bail out and you
know home mortgage you know wow you know
housing prices are so far below where
they were you know construction industry
is in a nascent recovery and we could
send ourselves back into a recession if
we did anything out like this then the
sort of all the complexity you know
unless you went into a long phasing
period which Donald has argued I think
quite persuasively would be a good thing
to do if we were gonna take this route
but I I sort of draw a parallel to 1983
and Social Security where we were in a
crisis and we had to do something and
one of the most important things we did
was to raise the age of normal
retirement where you got full benefits
from 65 to 67 the first person affected
wasn't affected for 17 years and you
know I'm all for that with respect to
some of these exclusions deductions and
so on but we don't have seventeen years
I don't think
well way to think is there is there a
way to build on this discussion of caps
and limits on deductions this goes back
to your revenue question earlier right
if there were an agreement that we need
to raise X amount of revenue or there
was an agreement that we're going to cut
rates by Y percent and need to pay for
it somehow that was shared and gave a
target then going after the exclusions
deductions right politicians call them
loopholes but you'll notice the geeks up
here aren't using that word but these
are the things often known as loopholes
you know that is in some sense in
principle the best way to go about it it
sounds really good in the abstract we
could all design for you a very nice
plan to do it but as bob says it becomes
very hard as people become increasingly
aware of what that means because the big
money is in health mortgages charity and
state and local taxes and people get
very twitchy when you start raising
those nonetheless as you said in your
opening question there has been interest
on both sides of the aisle to do this
right the president has a long-standing
proposal to reduce the value of
deductions and now exclusions for
high-income folks where it's a little
unclear now exactly what the cut-offs
were higher high income given what
happened in the deal but wherever that
is
and Governor Romney and others have put
forward proposals to cap deductions that
would effect kind of whole range of tax
payers and so that suggests that there's
interest there and that when the
pressure comes to find revenue from a
pool that's where you go shopping but
again it's unclear when that pressure
comes well I was a bit concerned as to
where the discussion was going when they
were talking about say a $50,000 cap on
deductions or talk about lowering the
value of every deduction to say a credit
of 28% or whatever
that leaves the tax code even messier
than it is today so I really think the
true tax reform would involve getting
rid as many deductions as you could now
I'm not so naive as to believe that you
could get rid of them all I think
bowles-simpson and what I would consider
there
most reasonable proposal did limit the
value of the very sensitive ones like
the home mortgage interest deduction
charities and so on to a 28% credit but
did advocate getting rid of a lot of the
rest of the underbrush and the tax code
and I think that's the minimal amount we
should try to achieve let me talk about
spending a little bit and actually the
first question asked is effects about
spending in taxes and this is issue of
chained CPI which also came up in the
discussion it appeared that the
administration should briefly supported
this idea well what do you think of it
is it a good idea to go to chain CPI you
know you can look at this from a couple
of different perspectives and the
chained CPI is a more accurate
reflection of overall inflation than the
CPI measure cpi-w which we use to adjust
federal benefit programs that said there
is a certain literature that suggests
and work by BLS and census that suggests
that for the basket of goods that the
elderly purchase in fact it's not very
good that that is that index of
inflation is slightly higher than the
one we use now so you know even if you
were gonna you know this this were a
policy debate in seminar room in a
university and you're saying what is the
right thing to use to adjust benefits
for the elderly and the disabled you
probably wouldn't go to a change CPI
even though you would say well for the
tax system or for some other aspect of
America's fiscal policy it would be a
more accurate thing to do then stand
back and look at this a different way
which is if we impose to change CPI
benefits for the elderly and the
disabled over time would be slightly
lower and who would they be
most affecting and the answer is this is
these are just Minar made to people's
benefit once they become eligible and
begin receiving benefits so you know
your first year on Social Security or
second year you're benefitted be maybe
three tenths of a percentage point less
than it otherwise would be for somebody
have been on ten years your benefit
would be three percent less so if you're
saying to yourself I want to cut
benefits I want to take some money out
of benefits would you say I want to
effect least those individuals who are
not dependent not as dependent on their
Social Security benefits because they
might be working part on because they're
you know 66 67 years old their pensions
from Ohio raised and other retirement
income is at its greatest but then you
look at the person who's 85 or 86 and
often the pension wasn't indexed so
their money is less their spouse has
passed away they're in in general
tougher financial circumstances so you
know I'd be it's not that I wouldn't
have some sympathy for changing benefits
but what I'd like to do is lower the
most for those who are most capable of
withstanding the reduction really who do
you think well I think the most
important point to make about the
chained CPI is that it really saves you
very little
and in the long run and raises you very
little on the tax side so if that's the
only thing we're contemplating and it's
that seemed to be the case well I guess
we talked about increasing eligibility
age for Medicare as well but we were not
talking about sufficient reforms to fix
fix the problem we faced one thing that
this discussion though is well
historically the chain CP I may have
gone up by two or three tenths of a
percent less than the CPI W that we use
there's no guarantee effect that is just
a forecast it's not a promise and we
could save much more by doing it or save
a lot less depending and how things
worked out but in terms of real reform
again I I would much rather look at
something of the sort that Bob discussed
some sort of progressive indexing
approach to the problem which did lower
the rate of growth of real benefits at
the top more than at the bottom and I
emphasize rate of growth because if you
look again at bowles-simpson proposal
all benefits continued to rise in real
terms even among the more affluent as
measured by lifetime wages so we don't
have to impose a huge amount of pain to
resolve the social security question so
I say the best for last which is
Medicare and I have to say it was
remarkable to me that during the entire
fiscal cliff debate the political system
was essentially silent on the issue of
Medicare but all his talk of course
earlier House Republicans had voted for
a fairly dramatic change in structure of
Medicare but during the fiscal cliff
debate over the last month or so I've
heard almost no words about Medicare
seems that everybody both parties were
terrified about even talking about this
Rudy what what was going on and and
and and are there ways to get sufficient
money from Medicare to address the
fiscal issue without entirely reforming
a system
well I think it's evident what was going
on Social Security and Medicare must be
the two most politically popular
programs ever invented and you know they
affect a huge number of people so it
really is really is hard for politicians
to attack those those programs I don't
know what you do to make reform more
acceptable and that's why I'm basically
so pessimistic for the long run I think
it will take some sort of crises to get
reforms and those very popular programs
what do you think are there ways to skin
the Medicare cat without committing
political suicide well you know the
president has proposed you know three to
four hundred billion dollars over ten
years of additional adjustments to
Medicare expanding on some of the ideas
in the Affordable Care Act cap you know
liberal organization has also put out a
plan with equal savings so there are
ways to do this
they don't constitute you know will form
writ large you know the fact is that
when we look at Medicare you know the
growth of spending on a per beneficiary
rate basis is going to be very low over
the next ten years because of changes
that were made in the Affordable Care
Act you know we're talking about growth
rates per beneficiary that are like half
of what they've been historically so you
know flu hard to see how you can squeeze
a whole lot more out of that in the
short run
and the longer-run I think sort of some
fundamental reforms are possible but you
know the president made this a defining
issue in the election and you know that
he was going to preserve your Medicare
and you know it was unrealistic to
expect that this would be front and
center in fiscal cliff negotiations well
the president on one hand says that he
does not favor any sort of premium
support system in Medicare on the other
hand he says that he does favor
increasing use of managed care in
Medicare does that in some sense get us
to the same place with a different name
you know as you know I have a certain
track record with premium support which
is actually a label that came out of an
article that Henry Aaron and I wrote
back in 1995 but it was a very different
approach not a moderately different
approach from what congressman Ryan has
pursued so I in fact have a lot of
sympathy from moving in that direction
in a sensible kind of way and we already
have the Medicare Advantage component of
Medicare we're about a quarter of
Medicare beneficiaries choose to get
their Medicare benefits through a plan
that is offered by some private entity
that agrees to take a risk adjusted
capitated payment to cover Medicare type
benefits for people who enroll in it and
modifying that program gradually over a
decade or so I think would move you very
close to something that congressman Ryan
would view as premium support but you
know we're not going to get gobs of
money out of it I mean the real issue
here is not Medicare or even Medicaid it
the underlying growth in health
expenditures per beneficiary in the
system at large I mean those of us on
Medicare get our benefits from the same
providers and through the same
mechanisms that employer sponsored
insurance folks do and you got a
institute reforms or changes in
incentives that will lower the growth
rate for all Americans and that's the
only way to be successful unless you
think you're going to shift costs on to
Medicare beneficiaries and that has huge
limitations because the average single
person over 65 has a median income of
about $18,000 and over half of the
unit's 65 years old and over our single
as opposed to couples and the couple
median income is only 44,000 so you
can't expect to get huge amounts of
money by shifting costs onto them okay
I'm going to give the audience a chance
to ask a few questions
there will be microphones that'll be
taken around and like you to wait until
you get a microphone please introduce
yourself and again please make it a
question and not a speech yes all right
back here
fiscal economists what does anybody up
there think about this centrist caucus
that's actually getting kicked off this
week I understand no labels that the air
our expectations of having people in
both houses of Congress trying to work
across the aisles people in more of the
middle-of-the-road background you know
there are many bipartisan groups that
have been floating around everybody on
this panel is participated in in some of
them do you see any opportunities at all
coming from from these well ultimately
it's the only way out but what we see in
the Congress is continued polarization
and erosion of the middle Blue Dog
Democrats and moderate Republicans
disappearing and we see unfortunately I
think more polarization on the part of
the voters do which is exaggerated from
the point of view of the house by the
fact that we're so clever at drawing
district lines that we tend to a draw
around conservative bunches and liberal
benches so when some Congress person
seems to be acting out of the mainstream
he or she may be from the point of view
of the nation as a whole but from the
point of view of their constituency
they're just going along with public
opinion so it's it's very very difficult
to break through that yes or gently in
the back
Oh name is Calvin girlie quick one
announcement in question and reading
article says that should you die in 2013
it said that estate tax as a state of
death taxes went about 20 percent from
35 to 55 percent I'm very upset with
that but why I can understand the
President and probably to Congress
because you have campaign contributions
and K Street lobbyists why is corporate
tax breaks not on the table discussion I
said all the focuses are at working
folks at the exemptions and our mortgage
exemptions and also social programs but
there's no focus there's no attack
there's no evaluation of corporate tax
breaks in this discussion or even with
the Congress I already gave Congress
their excuse because of the lobby is
campaign contributions okay thank you I
think there's two questions there one of
them is about the estate tax and maybe
even clarify what the rules are and then
the other one is about the extenders
which got extended so why don't you
clarify the estate tax first and then
how that passed when they state tax but
I will I will focus on the corporate
part the so go back to the presidential
campaign
you had one candidate Governor Romney
who proposed lowering the corporate tax
rate from its current 35 percent level
down to 25 you know the other candidate
President Obama now reelected who
proposed to lower the top corporate tax
rate from 35% down to 28% there was
actually a very strong bipartisan
interest in lowing lowering the
statutory corporate tax rate primarily
because of reasons of international
competitiveness the United States is now
quite out of line with much of the rest
of the world about what our tax rate is
on the other hand we're also
out of line in how generous our tax
breaks are right your point is that the
United States all else equal is a quite
high tax break country what President
Obama has proposed in broad terms is
rolling back corporate tax breaks as a
way to help pay for lowering the top
rate it's something that Dave camp and
others in the Congress have embraced as
well they're always the usual issues
about how far you can go in rolling back
tax breaks once the companies and
businesses know that that's what you're
trying to do and different businesses
have different opinions but that the
political discussion has primarily been
around revenue neutral business or
corporate tax reform in which rolling
back the tax breaks would be an
important part but it would be a pay-for
in order to bring the top rate down
really do you think there's a way we can
do corporate reform in this environment
a revenue neutral corporate reform in
this environment dealing with some of
these preferences well it it's extremely
difficult but I think one really
positive thing that came out of this
fiscal debate this time is for the first
time in a long time the business
community unified around the concept of
getting our deficit under control and
they weren't as worried about their
individual tax breaks that might go as a
result of having some reform so I hope
that mood continues so that people you
know one set doesn't argue about LIFO
versus FIFO this set doesn't argue about
accelerated depreciation and so forth
I'm more hopeful that that a more
unified view from the business community
is possible this time than it has been
for a very long time well I just want to
say one thing and I'm not fully
knowledgeable in this and Donald can
confirm or reject this and I was at a
meeting earlier today
where
a noted tax expert said you can't do
corporate reform and not do individual
reform because when we set the change
change the parameters a whole lot of
entities shifted from C corporations to
other forms that were taxed in on the
individual side so if you lower rates on
in the corporate tax system and get away
with some of the preferences for oil and
gas and various things you'll get this
huge shift of people you know LLC's and
things out of the individual and into
lower rates in the corporate world and
net you'll lose money no I don't so I'm
gonna let the lose money part but this
is a very important thing if you think
and watch as politicians and policy
analysts talk about this and when they
use the word corporate and when they use
the word business for exactly as Bob is
describing there are a lot of businesses
that are structured as corporations but
they're also a lot of businesses that
are structured as limited liability
corporations as partnerships as S
corporations and the taxation of their
income happens through individual tax
returns not through a corporate tax
return and some companies have a choice
about how they want a structure and they
base that in part on tax considerations
and part on other things there's also
this issue that many of the tax breaks
that apply to corporations are really
business tax breaks and if you start
changing those right if you make them
less favorable as a way to raise money
in order to afford lowering rates
you may also at that time have the
effect of then raising taxes on the
businesses that are taxed on the
individual side that won't get the
benefit of a corporate rate cut
depending on how you structure this you
then run into both fundamental economic
issues about are you distorting that how
these company Hailey's businesses choose
to set themselves up and you also begin
to run into a political challenge that
if your goal is to lower the corporate
rate but to pay for it by rolling back
business tax breaks the bumper sticker
of what you've just done is you have cut
axes on large multinational corporations
and who have raised taxes on yeoman
small businesses now they're a bunch of
things that may not actually be true and
what I just said right there's been but
that's the bumper sticker that you're
walking into and then that starts to
bring this pressure well that once
you're touching the individual side you
may have to go all the way to
fundamental wholesale reform to have
something that's politically doable
thank you so we have a question from one
of our remote viewers which kind of gets
to the bottom line of taxes how much
revenue would it be reasonable to hope
to obtain from tax reform it's part of a
grand bargain for deficit reduction and
let's talk about it so we we know we're
all talking about the same thing they're
talking about revenue is a share of GDP
what how much would it be reasonable to
collect in a new tax code this is the
issue we discussed before about Congress
not being able to agree I wonder if we
can agree I start what do you think of a
reasonable number is out there first of
all I think you've got to separate the
revenue target from how you face it I
mean there's some better ways to raise
more money which would not be
inefficient I guess I I felt pretty good
about the kind of thing that both
Simpson was was suggesting which as I
remember I think initially it was about
80 billion a year something like that it
seemed quite reasonable I think very
obviously as we look forward we're going
to need more revenue than we have
collected historically as a percent of
GDP just because of what the
demographics are doing to a large part
of government spending so somewhere you
know around 22% or something like that
seems a reasonable goal to me but I
think that's a reasonable goal for the
short term I mean
you know if I were looking out to the
mid-2020s I think it's going to end up
being hired don't you think so you tell
me what the spending is in percentage of
GDP and then I'll tell you two
percentage points less maybe a little
bit closer but you know I mean
aspirationally people talk about
balanced budgets and it's fun to talk
about those but realistically to get the
debt on this trajectory where it stops
growing faster the economy and starts
coming down something like running two
percentage point of GDP deficits on
average would be a tremendous
accomplishment relative to where we
stand today and so but you ultimately
have to calibrate our tax revenue versus
what spending is and to get there I
think it's important to think about tax
reform really quite broadly that it's
not necessarily just a matter of rolling
back tax breaks and adjusting the known
pieces of the code but at some point
quickly for at spending levels that
these two gentlemen were suggesting
thinking about things like carbon taxes
and whatnot may be essential leaving
aside environmental considerations may
be essential and raising that kind of
revenue so they're applying spending in
the twenty four twenty five percent of
GDP range is that credible to you
Krabbe incredible in the sense that we
could design a tax systems to support
them yeah it's hard to scale what we
have currently is an income tax to
accomplish that you would really have to
reduce the deductions a lot and if you
look internationally there are a bunch
of countries that have larger
governments than the United States does
a lot of that has to do with financing
of healthcare but some of it has to do
with other things and if you compare
their tax codes they by and large on
average choose to tax consumption more
heavily relative to income than we do
and there are a lot of good economic
reasons for why taxing consumption makes
more sense than taxing than taxing
income you know everyone doesn't mix
this is not an either/or thing but it
seems like the political economic
pressure is that if you want to support
a larger government you've got to have a
more efficient tax system that means
getting rid of lots of distortions it
means taxing more heavily consumption
and
of terms and the US would have to find a
way to get there right some people talk
about value-added taxes as a way to get
there I maybe I'm being Pollyanna again
or whatever you know I'm kind of firmly
of the belief that we end up at a carbon
tax before we get to a VAT in this
country but that's my political judgment
Rudy let me ask you as somebody who
designed a consumption tax once do you
think we're reaching the limits of the
income tax and we're gonna have to raise
these kinds of revenues from something
else well I used to think that the
politics would push us in that direction
but frankly I think as hard as reforming
the personal and corporate income tax is
coming up with a new tax at this
appointment point in time I think is
totally unthinkable from the Republican
point of view and I just can't imagine
doing it within the next 10 years or so
what were you thinking my observation
about this would be you know not to ask
the question what percent of GDP is
total spending going to be but what is
going to happen to health care cost
growth over the next decade and a half
and if we get it under control
I think our numbers can be you know
significantly lower and the sort of what
we've seen over the last three or four
years is very optimistic in the sense
that health care costs growth has slowed
down but we've been there once before
and you know it didn't pan out I'm
actually a believer that there are a
number of forces that should make us
more optimistic now than we were the
last time this happened thanks all the
questions from the audience yes sir I
know it's our hands
morever associate union news the whole
point of the fiscal cliff from the whole
point of the simpson-bowles everything
else was to try to get the deficit down
the long-term deficit down we haven't
talked about the other obvious way to do
it it's a four-letter word it's called
jobs I realize this is a tax but if you
put people to work they earn money even
if it's another government job
if they were money they pay taxes on it
if they pay taxes on it revenue goes up
and the deficit goes down talk about why
we haven't seen any jobs bills or anyone
talk about growing our way out of the
deficit well everything you said is true
such that growth is beneficial but the
net benefits I think are much lower than
a lot of people realize the problem is
that we've designed a system where we've
have for example index the initial
social security benefits to wages so
what that means is that the faster the
economy grows the faster wages grow the
faster the cost of our promises grow
with health it's a little more obscure
but I think the evidence is fairly clear
that if people have more income they
demand more health care and as a result
of that if you grow faster they'll
probably be more pressure on health care
costs so while growth has a net benefit
you can't solve the budget problem with
with realistic rates of growth we'd have
to grow a Chinese proportions to be able
to do that and with what is possible in
the United States yeah it would benefit
us I don't want to deny that but we
can't grow our way out of this problem
another question from the audience yes
sir
Thank You Larry Cheka Cheka
communications my question has to do we
talked about fed I'm sorry we talked
about the Congress and we talked about
the White House what what implications
does federal policy have for our
economic future mr. Bernanke well I
think well let me put it this way I
can't believe that the the quantitative
easing we've had has done all that much
good I mean I think the effects must be
trivial on interest rates and the
effects of more liquidity I think are
pretty trivial given that the banking
system hasn't been using their excess
reserves so I don't think it was worth
the risk of so exploding the Fed balance
sheet a balance sheet that will have to
shrink over the long run or else we do
create the risk of more inflation so I
wish the Fed hadn't done all of that
I guess though I'm not as concerned as
many people are that they were going to
make a huge mistake as they begin to
shrink the balance sheet it's hard to
believe that they can do it with
precision to come to a perfect outcome
they're bound to make a mistake one way
or another and I think by the way making
the mistake in the more contractionary
direction as just as probable is making
it in an inflationary direction so the
risks are there I don't think the risks
are high but I don't think it was worth
doing what they've been doing
well should they have done it and can
they unwind it yes I'm a little more
charitable on doing it I agree with Rudy
that I don't think the impact is
been huge and I think I like Rudy would
not want to be Ben Bernanke's successor
I'll beat them I'll be the most positive
I think I think that has the risk
profile is that it's much worse to do to
a little than too much for the Fed not
least because for quite easier syncretic
reasons in the middle of the in the
middle of the financial crisis the
Federal Reserve got new authority to pay
interest on reserves which is actually a
new tool it has to combat inflationary
pressures whenever that time comes that
time has not yet come but when it does
and so while it has built up its balance
sheets to unforeseen levels and we're a
new area in federal p.m. Fed policy I
think the reality is that Ben Bernanke
or his successor will be in a very
strong position to combine combat any
inflationary pressures that may come
down the road and then in the meanwhile
given out tepid the recovery has been
weaning on the side of doing more it's
been the right choice
so Donal we will end on a relatively
optimistic note thank you very much
thank you - Donald - Rudy and and - Bob
rush hour
No
and as always if you missed any of the
discussion on the fiscal cliff here at
the Urban Institute it's in our video
library at c-span Don or come